[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
deep
[Music]
I'm a plain simple and I have played
some feelings and I use planes in two
words and I simply have to let you go a
plainly then I use ice namely ampullae
what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you rather nice then you having oh no
really I think you ought to give him a
chance he seems kind of hopeless
helplessness is the last thing I am
looking for
[Music]
[Music]
even chamois
[Music]
[Music]
even Sammy please if we're going to
spend the rest of our lives together you
must learn not to interrupt mr. panner
[Music]
[Music]
you realize what you've saved I should
do it's pounded to my brain often enough
asleep and awake in the drowsy fantasy
moment of every lonely dawn oh come on
what's your answer you take my breath
away
oh it's just the sudden realization to
see from the vector that I love you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Music]
say hi
[Music]
say hi
[Music]
[Music]
hi
sacred beer hi
somewhere
somewhere
[Music]
they're high
[Music]
[Music]
for every
[Music]
cept for every
[Music]
for every
[Music]
[Music]
Minister
right
[Music]
no reason
[Music]
for every
[Music]
cept for every
[Music]
for everything
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
there's embossing some ducks and dogs
and bears and horses and dogs dogs and
fossils and chairs and fossils and rocks
and fossils and gas dogs and horses and
cows and horses and dogs and horses and
dogs and gases
dogs and dogs and gas
[Music]
dolphins dolphins and gas and gas
[Music]
dear me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dolphins and dolphins and dogs don't
talk
that was a nice thing to hear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
large sized women
[Music]
schedule
[Music]
you're some stream
why is it always me
no such dream
[Music]
Brent I populace Facebook paintings too
[Music]
populace
[Music]
[Music]
lahter with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and Betty mid the
coronavirus chaos Chinatown has been
seeing fewer visitors but city officials
say there is no reason to be concerned
it's absolutely safe to enjoy all that
Chinatown has to offer
one awesome our China Town thing you
know
and the support I don't have support
right now
wondering it
[Music]
Hey too many back comes from China
[Music]
9/11 was nothing compares to this Lane
the Chinese
so it's true they say xenophobia is at a
high
[Music]
Goodman
go
to stay
[Applause]
stay home everyoneís has blood on his
head we lose left to get the time
the curve continues to go up
[Music]
petitions are now working to combat
racism Chinese
well it's true Chinese started the the
como virus
[Music]
just
stay at home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the the Backstreet Boys
and back they did this and I'm just
doing it because I don't think it's my
foot is in an ice bath right now Wow
because I cause great bodily harm we
have Anthony ku Mia on the show let me
guys Stu is here of course from the book
and go to youtube.com slash Stu does
America show yes we have to change that
yes he does no one will find you
quarterblack I don't like it
audio way too cute Maddie Gerald a
what's the one of the day one of the day
is summit vine diamond summit vine what
is Dumont how is it spelled D I am a 73%
merlot it's just a show it's about the
news okay and we screw around a lot and
make fun of you know China causing
global pandemics nice there's a
compression it happened there's a racist
compression in room it's just this is
warming we anthony lumia on the show and
of course for people who don't know it's
Mudd Club quarantine months that's the
hash tag entering the promo code
quarantine you get $30 off a lot of
credit a comm slash Mudd Club and we are
double income we're doing more content
than ever before and we're putting it
all in front of the paywall this month
and if you remember please do consider
renewing also announcement starting next
Monday everything is going to Bree Bree
Bree I do I do like I prefer sharp
cheddar everything's going to released
Wow 8 p.m. Eastern
so right now Jim is at 8:00 Eastern and
then the uploads are at 9:00 and I don't
know why that happened gross oversight
on my part and people in different days
I didn't have an answer for you and so I
was upset with myself as well you should
be some now we have it going so tomorrow
also a good morning one club that's
every Monday Wednesday Friday
announcement question of the day before
we move on is where do you think the
balance is between worrying about health
with the country with the globe as well
as taking into account economic
viability particularly as it relates to
the working class and when do you think
it's time to start turning the economy
back on who thought that the the
greatest act of rebellion one could
undertake is wanting to work
it's punk-rocker 80s Punk for the
economy should be in rancid no are you
drunk
no I'm not I'm not a singer I'm a
stylist well let's just oh my god chalk
it up to that's fine then but first I
know a lot of people are bored I know a
lot of people are boring are any of you
but not as much as this guy not because
it's so perfect like switches the shadow
like a film production I was trying to
keep a pg-13 rating it looks like the
ghost of the darkness we don't remember
this
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's putting it out by hitting him in
the side here's why I don't think it's
fake its fake let me list my
justification for you some people have
gone back and forth first off is put on
the makeup I'm a little really hip and
and Chinese people can't act so like
they do that compare don't like the
comedy of something played so
straight-laced
than it's embarrassing yeah I mean yeah
yeah I don't know I feel like you know
for them it'd be like a paper mache hat
and like they wouldn't do this a bit oh
yeah and play it dry the guy that burned
his balls off on tape yeah that's how
you feel after a night with Kesha if you
wake up the next morning brushes her
teeth with a bottle of Jack I don't know
who does that nobody Korres Bernie
Sanders of course has suspended his
campaign by the way I should say we'll
be talking about the World Health
Organization a little bit because I'm
sort of tearing a page from our book but
Bernie Sanders suspend his campaign
here's the thing he held in for as long
as he could I know we've given him a
hard time but we don't hate any of these
people a fighter he's a worthy adversary
or he was but as for Bernie right now
it's copyright-free
time to close he did not work till he
was like 41 and then he got elected to
something it was all just baloney and I
feel so bad that you know people got
sucked into it wow that's travel time
too
endings and beginnings are ending and
beginning
no time to close it's time to go to
places where you go to raise yourself I
am NOT a billionaire millionaire
billionaire billionaire millionaires
billionaires millionaires and
billionaires Democratic Socialist Bernie
Sanders confirming he is a millionaire
and offering no apologies billionaires
just the billionaire class it's time for
things to close things two people are
lining up the food that's a good thing
[Music]
to be clear he's not actually dead no I
want to make sure that doesn't go out I
don't want to get smoked just campaign
his hopes and dreams it's kind of
endearing you know that he was struck
out by a seven-year-old because Joe
Biden
there is no semblance of even trying to
be cool like Joe Biden still try or I
just named Elizabeth Elizabeth Warren
they're easy to forget there's like when
you're kind of one foot in one foot out
you know like you're showing up at the
Apollo Theater trying to get votes
Bernie when you look like I Gore from
Young Frankenstein you know what he just
he limped up and you try to lay up and
how we expected yeah yeah anybody
expects him to be able to be good at
basketball I don't think people expect
him to be good at things
also on Wednesday by the way Trump
president Trump was asked about hey let
me ask you this should I not how long
can I leave my foot in an ice bath for a
long time okay cuz it's been in for like
an hour yeah I don't supposed to do that
no it's okay I think we should leave it
you want my foot to be frost it won't
get frostbitten oh my word okay I'm
taking it out what the hell did you do
to it nice I'm just a I'm a puppy and so
I unbreakable I'm like mr. glass okay
yeah without the hood pass goodness you
don't even concerned
oh yes ice for an hour before and fell
asleep like you saw get in okay yes so
Wednesday president Trump was asked I'm
gonna try and continue like I'm not
entirely distracted by my throbbing it
looks like Fred Flintstone after he
screwed up the bowling at the water but
is
expect it to look like your forehead
okay there's an H in there sir yeah
that's that's not what a human foot
smells and the worst part about it is
that I know someone is doing ungodly
things in themselves because I just
showed my feet I don't know probably
would be so if President Donald Trump he
was asked about giving a pardon to the
tiger king yeah and I think these kind
of clips a lot of people miss is when he
seems endearing he was asked about Joe
exotic I was playing I was wondering if
you've seen showin if you have any
thoughts on Courtney because you think
he didn't do it
are you on whose side are you
recommending a pardon no I'm not
advocating as a reporter you're not
allowed to do that you'd be criticized
by these would you recommend a pardon
I'm not weighing it I don't think you
would I don't think you would go ahead
you have a question I'll take a look
hide you never recommend a partner for
that one reporters comb over at a
certain point you just go American
History X you really anybody it was a
son Don jr. - but people think like
someone I'm not at you know I'm not a
very good liar people like that who lie
because his whole head is a lie do they
feel comfortable like like even though
just a stiff wind will blow it all the
lid Oh on off the whole thing I am no
idea Stan thoughts do I'm the tiger
thing is interesting with Trump because
this is an opportunity where the kind of
the can grab on to you disgusting and
what do you think giant massive yeah you
just gotta amputate that thing I do know
in the water it reminds me of my teacher
from you know I'll use his name I don't
care I'm tired
Rocco bono was my gym class teacher info
so he actually sent me outside to run a
1k run and I got frostbite really yeah
oh that's right you look like that
looked like this yeah a little worse so
Donald Trump played don't bleep that he
played
about it I tried to play it coy of
course though he has had calls with yes
I think yeah
have you watched Tiger King I am three
episodes in that's all it needs to be
yeah it's seven episode arc it would
really be about 300 then really good it
starts off like a Christopher Guest
documentary there's no way these people
are real yes right
yeah yeah and then they are and there
was actually unfolding the onion was it
crazy was it you tell me audio it was it
doc doc antal yes jacket right flow
there to the two subjects of the
document have slammed the series as
salacious sensationalism right okay I
understand I understand that does happen
right with reality TV but hold on a
second I want to be clear
did this man run an illegal underground
tiger breeding ring along with two
husbands who were not even homosexual
and he hired a hitman to kill an animal
rights activist I'm okay with adding a
little zest like that's enough I don't
think you're too far from the crazy
three line oh man there's so much
there's a way he's married to because I
feel like Trump would like the guy who
was married to four wives then the guy
who's married to two husbands but the
two husbands are not well no no no your
spoiler we have two was three in there
not really gay
and the guys reason is 20 Tigers is 20
Tigers no no I'm completely straight
what are those Tigers yeah
like someone's wrinkled fairy dust just
on your rear out the window with the the
English Sheepdog so in entertainment
news um it's the same as having wings
isn't that the you think of Santa think
of snow think of reindeer we go
in entertainment news thank you very
least quarter bladder song of a harmony
ever he doesn't mean Garfunkel to know
Paul signers just guard its enraging I
tell you our girl Frankel came in when
we were taping Arthur yeah all
instructors have here you have time like
do not mention Paul Simon and I was 12
well Mike I don't know that history of
this boy so I'm just like hey what's up
with Paul Simon like no disturber what
yeah what else oh and interesting that's
right on Zimmer for those who don't know
the composer of the music for inception
Dark Knight the whole trilogy he's filed
for divorce
which is said when asked how the divorce
would affect his children Zimmer
responded
hmm interesting yeah yeah expected was a
thinker that jerk
we couldn't get danny elfman when
everyone was everyone's been making
adjustments to be in porn porn like it's
so it's to me that so funny I'm just
trying to keep a straight face yeah yeah
because if I sit down Jimmy Fallon like
Hans Zimmer does it's right shut up
Jimmy you brought it back
we're being quarantine a pornography
company they're helping performers
safely shoot videos at home on Monday I
want to make sure you let's write vixen
Media Group announced that it plans to
make this transition easier for some
performers by sending them customized
packages including cameras ring lights
toys and lingerie so they can more
easily work from home in total the
packages will be worth $250,000 in an
effort to combat coronavirus still no
word however on the incurable AIDS
nothing at home yeah it's a shame
crippling really turning to science dark
ending to that story if you use needles
you're fine don't listen to Oprah two
and three heterosexual couples by 1994
will get AIDS
drinking sounded like it went from 2.5
million minimum deaths to one hundred
thousand to two hundred and forty
thousand minimum now it's like sixty
thousand minimum and at any point
someone said minimum denier exactly you
didn't do you deny science not your bush
hey guys turning sorry the bleep button
actually at the authenticity of these
movies because so much porn is done at
office settings casting couches can't be
done authentically at home that's true
that's not right Wow right the mouse
can't hit on the secretary authentically
at home that's true they need to meet
they need to be make real moves to make
this happen to need to get them back
into the workforce yeah use a story yeah
Wow
at least get him you know get them all
in Chatsworth and just quarantine them I
guess that's a little bit of that's a
little regional
humor in California terrorists where
they shoot all the pornography oh it was
funny when I thought of it not so much
now so science that's a thing a team of
researchers they've actually developed a
smart toilet yes with for camp why no
the rest of it why how much prep Gerald
a does age well for him well it's going
to age about as well as anyone who said
trust the world you know will age well
don't test China as Rushmore it's true
they're gonna kill him a team of
research the developed of smart toilet
with four cameras that can identify
users based on their quote email print
this comes from vice yeah each user of
the toilet is identified through their
fingerprint and the data is securely
stored now there's an argument
especially now with a new economy of
where we'll end up with automation kind
of hitting the reset button right now
and striking that balance though some
would argue that it's become invasive
and in this instance the technology has
just gone too far Brendon hey how you
doing good staying healthy yeah yeah
staying healthy good good health is the
most important thing to have yeah for
sure yeah you got any plans after this
no price gonna grab lunch or something
lunch nice it's important to stay fed
mmm-hmm I haven't eaten yet I don't want
to he just wants a friend that's why I
live in a cabin and I don't even have a
rotary phone um I like the idea for four
cameras in a toilet could be another
thing the porn companies yeah for
equipment
well they do just the actresses don't
know it's just just a man from Hong Kong
okay finally we'll just remove that
entirely for yourself I'm joking we
can't remove it we're not rhett and Link
they drew first blade myself Turks I
really want them to I don't I I want
them to come back to do these because I
don't want them to go to hell finally a
man dressed up that's the same reason to
have a problem with Islam dressed up as
a popular children's - oh come on
everyone gets quite a bad you know I
just I always find that so funny when
people get mad that you're like I think
Mohammed is a false prophet
really that's I can't believe you would
say that well one a second he said that
everything Jesus said was wrong was
wrong didn't mean that okay
finally there was a man he dressed up as
a popular children's dinosaur you know
Barney to visit a young girl during
quarantine we have a picture of the man
in question which does seem to he just
seems to have free rein now that
Bernie's dropped out oh yeah you're
gonna find Unchained yeah well yeah they
had to go with the youthful option of
the - yeah he's 77 yes you had to go
young you know rain is deteriorated
beyond recognition but you know he still
walks right yeah I think if they do a
ctrl delete on him occasionally right
okay that's the problem they never
reboot him he doesn't he doesn't know
how to reboot hmm he's on phone with
tech support because he wants to
outsource all American jobs what huh I
don't have a keyboard that's tough yes
sir that's a typewriter who stopped
really that was Barney it's been it's
been biting all along that we should
looking back we should have seen this
coming are you ready kids
but okay
I sniff you you touch me
just don't tell your family with a great
baby and a touch from - whoa choose my
Wow I think it makes sense yeah that's
right Barney no learn how to curse
properly language Joe do you have to
believe I don't believe so noise
there'll be 20 YouTube videos of people
trying to crack that code yeah I
guarantee you no one will come close
here's the thing with Joe Biden in
talking about will get back to the World
Health Organization because that's why
you're here but no no no honestly with
Joe Biden here I think he's in trouble
we've been talking about it for a long
time people are joking I don't think
it's funny anymore
did you guys see is the most recent
gaffe of the case what we cannot let
this we've never allowed any crisis from
the Civil War straight through to that
pandemic is 17 all the way around 16 we
have never never let our democracy sakes
second fiddle way that we can both have
a democracy and the elections and at the
same time correct the public health
if I can meet a crutch but I like it
it's helpful thank you Hans
yeah sorry about your divorce
but um yeah that sucks yeah
hey again it's hashtag moto corn mug
Club quarantine enter in the promo code
quarantine $30 off we have some fans
from the week quarterblack bring them up
who do we got we got a JT David D and
David Englehart also there Wow know what
that's the black rifle coffee of the
Month Club and I am not yet received
that I can't and they say it's full hey
black rifle can you find me can you
return a call please I've been waiting
on that for a long time I want to try
the is single origin Ethiopian Union
chef because I'm an effective listening
there are no respecter of persons Steven
you will wait in line like everyone else
[Music]
let's be honest I should be treated like
royalty I'm not gonna I'm not gonna have
I'm not gonna sleep with my sister I
want the perks let's go to you right now
everyone's been talking we talked about
it initially over a week ago the World
Health Organization yes pacifically in
addressing China and now I know that a
lot of other people sort of been picking
up these talking points which is a great
thing finally but let's get specifically
into how they are synonymous and really
everything wrong with the World Health
Organization
I think this is the first time we've
done it with an organization I think
individuals up until now they're number
one to t so if people have been
following you know they've been actually
trending this week as people they've
been celebrating the anniversary of the
World Health Organization's founding I
guess as a celebratory saying this is
what they do it was on 7th April 1948
that Dabney Joe came into being because
I want my ambassador to be Neil deGrasse
Tyson had sex with a Somali pirate of
course it's a joke gay men can't make
babies oh how it works of course
everyone I'll say everyone they love and
they trust the World Health Organization
and that's what we have CBS ABC NBC
they've decided to come together to air
the World Health Organization can you
say who from now on yes please do bring
the foot back up I will bring it I will
be a spite foot so everyone here stay in
line it's one world together at home
it's an event with Colbert Kimmel and
Jimmy Fallon hosting this is another
example you know they say like well this
is just about humanity it's not
political and I just don't I just don't
think they understand that they have a
blind spot that the World Health
Organization who I'm sorry I just don't
like abbreviations it is it is a
political wing yes they do have a
political agenda and unfortunately it's
aligned with people who hate everything
the United States is about you know what
I really just want the left to
understand this let's not even look at
the fact that they hate America I get it
you hate America so you want to link
arms how about the fact that you cannot
boycott the gap and support an
organization that excludes Taiwan and
supports the most the most severe abuses
of human rights of any modernized
country right yeah and they do it under
the guise of world health rights right
obviously they're just to help us that
this you know great wing and right you
start digging in a little bit and this
kind of freaks you out we'll get to some
of those points yeah and I think a lot
of people may say well why it has Trump
but know this once explain why he's
obviously been bashing who for how it
handled the outbreak was coronavirus and
he threatened to cut their funding of
course the media is beside themselves
the w-h-o sent out multiple
coronavirus alerts earlier this year in
fact declaring it a global health
emergency back in January the president
largely dismissed those warnings saying
also in January it's gonna be just fine
that's a direct quote now has been tracy
reports mr. Trump claims the w-h-o
failed they call it wrong they really
they missed the call the president is
shifting blame for the spread of the
corona virus to the World Health
Organization I don't know if it's
shifting if just keeping it exactly
where it always should have been
yeah could someone shift the dining room
tip no it's where it's always been you
shifty senator so the anchor you see
that and you've worked in media for so
long you see what's happening there if
the anchor is giving this impression
that that who was declaring coronavirus
a global health emergency well Trump was
ignoring it right Trump declared
coronavirus a public health emergency
the very same day that who made the
declaration really an issue that he
restricted travel from China
how did who how did the who it not the
who raised compression yeah racism this
room it's like when a pilot has to
compress the cabin right pilot had
disdain for an entire group of people of
course yeah no all groups of people
really technically an organization a
communist front organization effectively
so how do who how did they keep saying
the who wh oh no travel bans they just
they were against travel bans and they
would argue that it's not effective
listen if your country is one big giant
petri dish and they're lying about it I
think that putting a stop on leisurely
vacations is a good start probably a
good start yes yeah probably you know
you could still get flights from Wuhan
to JFK right now right now there's one
of it there's one seat available on
Saturdays flight I almost booked it just
so I could book it in then cancel it so
someone else didn't buy it right yeah
because I didn't seem like it was a good
idea to have any new visitors probably a
touring with Kevin Smith and then he
couldn't boogie he's like it's only one
seat
buckle this do I need to do I need to
lay down like Liam Neeson in the gray
they were praising by the way China's
handling of the sub of this pandemic
okay throughout the entire depending
over backward let's be clear about this
this is important the timeline matters
obviously not all Chinese people were
very clear about that I hate the Chinese
government and by proxy who because I
empathize with the Chinese people who
are abused and kept under the thumb of
the chai combs can I say that Jack I'm
Chinese economist because yeah or yes I
mean everything is considered racist but
I don't think that that's racist I come
okay that's fine I have no idea no I
don't you join my club quarantine $30
off because it gets better about may not
be here so they were praising China and
it matters as far as the temen because
all along the way China they were
destroying evidence of the virus when it
was first discovered they silenced
whistleblowers arrested them some of
them just disappeared because they were
kept in warrant conditions plus by the
way there were studies this is something
very important to keep in mind what
everyone wants to blame Donald Trump and
I understand if you want to have the
argument that it wasn't the ideal
response of course I get that but that's
been nearly everywhere particularly
China when you see on by a studies show
that if they'd have used the proper
mitigation techniques rather than
focusing on keeping up appearances love
in the who doing their dirty work
95 percent 95 percent of the cases
I mean how does the rest of the world
not lay that at like not the Chinese
people like okay can we all get past
that but I did it so that we can okay
okay good note that how do we not lay
that at their feet like wouldn't it put
it on us like what if we had done the
exact same remember the world lay that
at our feet they lay the economic profit
our land there minding feet the feet of
fury it's only ballerinas
[Applause]
eight you tell me size six
even mark you like to say something
there yeah maybe we should just reduce
their funding by ninety five percent yes
that would be a nice easy I agree we
give about ten times basically to the
Debbie hu almost nine hundred million
dollars to Hannah's ninety
I think same thing with NATO NATO I'm
not saying completely living it but you
know what everyone pledged to pay two
percent I think the average is like
point nine percent we paid three point
six how about this we're not only not
going to honor the agreement anymore not
two percent we will pay the exact
average of all other nations by the way
protect your own borders have fun yeah
good luck and here's what matters though
to has the World Health Organization
ever mentioned any of this mitigate if
it's the World Health Organization right
the fact that they lied about the virus
the fact that they silenced
whistleblowers many of whom disappeared
some of whom are dead and the fact that
they could have mitigated it by ninety
five percent if your goal is to be the
world health organization seems to me
that wouldn't matter if there's no
political motive if the goal is entirely
to solve the pandemic why not highlight
that international abuse of power yeah
instead not only they not do it they
just keep repeating Chinese propaganda
points without question that's the issue
here
yeah and in 2003 so just for a
comparison right so we're calling them
out in their response right now saying
Oh China did this and they're like oh no
that's not a big deal in 2003 China
responded the same way they always
respond to these kinds of things they
hid this information they didn't say
anything about it for the SARS outbreak
they were blasted by the WH o the WH o
actually had leadership that stood up to
China and said right that's not okay
same thing that they're doing now the
only thing that's changed Tedros guy and
talk about that in a second there's a
huge connection with him in China that
is very very interesting why he's not
going after them I appreciate it
there's a situation too with with the
Ebola thing that broke out in Liberia a
few years ago yeah
World Health Organization went in there
first and they said to everybody there
if you get Ebola you die so don't get it
right so the people were getting it and
we're like well I can't get any
treatment so I might as well just stay
home with my family and write and then
they spread it to all of their family
members it wasn't until organizations
like Samaritan's Purse and faith
organization right came in and said hey
guys you can get treated for this that
they actually were able to turn that
back yeah
but Franklin Graham doesn't believe that
Muhammad's preachings that Jesus was a
fraud is correct therefore he's a hate
monger and their work with Ebola doesn't
matter yes don't go to his best so don't
you forget your mistakes
Liberia keeping my eye and foot on you
by the way hit the notification bell if
you are not subscribed to monk oh but I
know that many of you aren't yet
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot hit
all notifications and do consider
subscribing to Crowder bits of course
the podcasts go it's not iTunes anymore
it's not powerful podcast podcast that's
so stupid yeah I think it makes more
sense to have the toilet robot yeah
really
you're on my side now yeah oh I never
was against it okay I just think it's
invasive but I like a little
invasiveness so here's another claim
that was made by the World Health
Organization they're repeated China's
lies about how coronavirus was spread
and they said that there was no evidence
no evidence of human human transmission
On January 12th now here's I want to be
clear and hold them to the same standard
so we hold everyone people can make
mistakes right people can be wrong for
example the Trump administration thought
that it wouldn't be as severe as it
would and that is true right they
declared an emergency same time timeline
but they didn't think would be as severe
because they were given information from
the World Health from China and the
World Health Organization corroborated
so I am NOT mad because they said no
evidence of human human transmission On
January 12th because they made a mistake
I'm mad because Taiwan directly gave you
evidence of human human transmission in
December they provided them with proof
of doctors getting sick from the corona
virus patients it was clear evidence of
human to human transmission so why would
the World Health Organization not listen
and also go out and tell everyone else
the exact opposite because they don't
even recognize Taiwan as its own state
yeah and that's one of the key reasons I
said it just a second ago Ted Rose was
elected in 2017 bday after he came out
and affirmed China's one China policy
meaning that Taiwan is not separate from
us they are a part of us right he was
backing their play up essentially saying
they don't get to see that he also just
there's there's so many horrible things
in that phrase you just threw one China
one-child policy and like it was a baby
in a ballast in China ones my point was
child 1 child
they said one Jang China Cancun climate
summit when I watched a Ted Turner
praised China's one-child now she's like
oh that's not your evil so one China not
one shot one chain they have like a
theme one something yeah see the child
China you know whatever Bob Marley's
rolling over in his grave I don't know
what one love means it's one dude you're
a [ __ ]
I just glad there could not get a
getting from information from Israel
because then they would never recognize
they would ask Pat they would ask
Palestine I'll attack any time I came by
the way this is a really bad job that's
like a celebrity boxing like a
paintbrush no because I have received
complaints to Twitter violations of
policies not from people in Pakistan
Pakistan the country of Pakistan
so that is one yeah one country on that
we got a lot more to go oh no I have a
lot more countries on there there's been
quite a few well not officially we need
to make that happen Oh officially oh
yeah yeah very officially not not not
casually oh it's not like Wacky
Wednesday where you you know you roll up
your high socks yeah kind of beheading
in Pakistan this is the full put me out
in a soccer field so the children can
throw dates at me oh okay figs I don't
know big states that grow at a drop
lineman so here's the thing too that
really does matter with Taiwan obviously
they deny Taiwan sovereignty so the who
they continue to block Taiwan for
membership because China doesn't
recognize them and this is important
because of the reason for Taiwan being a
separate state and that's because
specifically it applies to the gross
human abuses of human rights right get
out get out of the show map someone is
airing in the producer getting in the
show map I have these guy and they're
like in there I will murder you
changing them so they won't even let
Taiwan how to see at the table as an
observer no and the reason for that is
because Taiwan has been outspoken
against China this is something we've
shown before but I think it needs to be
seen as many times as possible
it says chilling
as a clip gets you don't need a
conspiracy watch what happens when a
World Health Organization official is
asked specifically about Taiwan the wao
considered Taiwan's membership question
okay let me let me repeat the question
because I'm I'm actually curious I'm
talking about Taiwan as well on Taiwan's
case Aaron Sorkin is surly horrible I
just imagine her pet doesn't work there
but if that was the level of
accountability from every international
organization yeah you know like the UN I
don't asking Donald Trump about
waterboarding like I don't like the
question about respond to it favorite
tree I didn't hear your question Kim
yeah and she goes no no no let's move on
to another one yeah it's just terrifying
yes Amen thanks dude yeah no no no I am
amazed by world the World Health
Organization now because they continue
to do this they do it with our money
yeah and mostly our money yeah mostly
our money and like look we do this is
the type of thing I hate international
organizations yeah this is a type of
thing though when you come to pandemics
it would actually be useful if they were
doing the job right like what they were
they did the job with smallpox very long
ago there's a role for an international
organization when you are trying to stop
an international spread of a virus yeah
that's different from the UN where it's
like we should all be nice to each other
and thank God for the USA yeah and well
the organization isn't needed for this
type of thing too right
in Liberia we are received very well
they're Americans we loved in Liberia so
we can go in there and use our expertise
and they're happy about it China's not
right they hide it from us and it turns
into something that's overturning
basically the entire global economy yeah
yeah well and so we're so interconnected
now we depend on an organization like
this to be able to go into a country
that isn't necessarily going to be
honest and be the honest voice the
adults in the room that
look this is really serious everybody
needs to get prepared so yeah we can all
we can all do this but now they have a
bias and if they're gonna have a bias
towards anybody nine hundred million
versus ninety million why in the hell
are you you're picking the guy that
gives you 90 million a year and it gives
you ten times that much you don't do
anything for and why the hell are they
so focused on oppressing a nation that
just wants their independence yeah like
listen left us out there you root for
the underdog that's the only way that
you could justifiably sort of go in to
bat for Palestine when they're launching
rockets from grade schools it's just
because they're really bad at war so you
feel sympathy for them I get it they
suck at war right I understand somehow
you want to give them the world high
ground how about Taiwan how about Taiwan
or were you 2-bit you forgot seven years
in Tibet it was pretty it was
forgettable wasn't a great the Chinese
are not your friend as you go out there
and check out sweatshops with Nike and
then say trust the World Health
Organization who's complicit and again
this matters because everyone has made
people have made mistakes and say across
the board but there is a stark contrast
between the approach of the media China
the World Health Organization and it's
important to remember that they've all
acted as one in the same right now and
President Donald Trump first off Taiwan
he's already hinted at recognizing time
wanted to ask he was the first United
States President to call Taiwan's
president since I think was at 79 nice
since 1979 I think great year and that
said of course the media into hysterics
they were furious about it and the truth
is too while we're talking about Taiwan
why it matters
first off it's reprehensible to not
listen to a country simply because you
want to assist in their oppression
because you like China that being said
from him from a pragmatic point of view
Taiwan handled the quraan over better
than almost any other country in large
part why because they don't trust
anything China says hmm they know them
too well they know them too well it was
similar to South Korean we'll get back
to that in a second it was one of the
earliest countries to be hit it has one
of the lowest infection rates and death
rates despite being right next to China
they almost entirely avoided the virus
their new cases peaked I think back in
March March something March twenty
twenty second twenty four so I'm like
that population of about twenty five
million people they've only have five
deaths also keep in mind
incredible population density yeah we're
not just talking about like why it's
spread across Wyoming here now how did
they pull this off Taiwan and World
Health Organization I hope you're
listening
because you might want to take some
notes they started inspecting passengers
from Wuhan all the way back into summer
they banned who Han residents and
suspended tours to China in January then
they banned all Chinese visitors
February 6th again you look at South
Korea what they did they didn't have a
full quarantine now granted they Doc's
they're citizens what you can't do here
in the United States and I don't think
we want to do it here now they acted
early on and they were immediately
skeptical of any information being fed
to them from China so this idea that
it's anti Asian no no just the
government of those asked I don't know
where there should I just say Asian I
don't want to say cuz we always used to
say Chinese people judgment in this case
Chinese Chinese Chinese Chinese Chinese
Chinese government only you only you not
the Koreans okay not the Taiwanese
Chinese bad yeah China s government we
focus on that or you can focus on the
fact that you're racist if you mentioned
that eating bats is a bad idea
yeah clear my opposition to them eating
bats has nothing to do with coronavirus
I just want them to stop it yes I don't
care if eating bats cured coronavirus I
would say still stop yeah creature sir I
will personally pay Sarah McLachlan's
royalties wow that almost was Sarah
bethought I really she's here yeah it's
the B side was that the International
sign for having bat suit I think it's
corn on the cob
you were talking about Melissa how dare
you let's go back to South Korea keep in
mind they began moving to create testing
kits January 16th yeah and again they
worked with private industry two weeks
before the World Health Organization
actually declared kovat an emergency so
this is important to note that Donald
Trump values Taiwan's approach so if you
want to talk about the Internet
National Committee and you want to talk
about who's supporting people in Y all
why is it racist for someone for example
to mention batsu or to mention the
Chinese communist government yeah but
you don't recognize that Donald Trump
actually is supporting the people the
Taiwanese people who've been oppressed
by China and the world doesn't even want
to recognize him doesn't even want to
talk about recognizing won't even let
them in the room because they're afraid
of offending China right that's it's
incredible to me I can understand we do
have to get to Anthony Kamiya and of
course it's a youtube.com slash stood as
America oh that's right yeah good name
to show horrible URL okay you think
Donald Trump should cut funding in the
World Health Organization here's
something else that people aren't
recognizing you know why the
working-class Americans when we're
talking about the Rust Belt don't think
that you're going in to bat for them do
you know why Joe Biden Bernie Sanders
because you don't even go into that for
the working class in China let alone
Taiwan these are people who are being
paid pennies a day to work in sweatshop
factories the World Health Organization
turns a blind eye the one nation that
tried to get themselves separate and say
hey we don't want to do it the way that
China does it Donald Trump says good on
you I'm going to actually try and
recognize you and support you
just like I support the steel mill will
worker in Pittsburgh in the World Health
Organization says no no no no we want to
stand with the government who oppresses
its people and then lies to the
working-class people across the pond
ensuring a pandemic when 95% of it could
have been mitigated had we just done our
job
I don't think we need to be funding the
World Health Organization at all if you
want to find someone to blame
you don't need to shift the blame from
Donald Trump to World Health
Organization you just need to keep it
squarely where it always was Chinese
government and the World Health
Organization we are cleaning up their
mess
no one's doing it perfectly but how
about we start with this let's look out
for the working class let's look out for
the underdog in this case it's the
underdog in the United States who've
been screwed by the international
economic crippling and the underdog in
Taiwan and also the underdog in China
when they're not a part of the elite
ruling class and the government or
Jackie Chan shooting propaganda
commercials for the government good god
can we return can we make them include
it in Red Dawn I can't believe
we cater to their stupid film market and
change it to North Korea we should have
seen the giant Chinese red flag flip
them the bird and said Wolverines
forever was it Wolverines Wolverines
don't believe China don't trust China
China asked all right Anthony come here
here we go my foot is really purple put
it away
[Music]
good made it excellent
now all you have to do is access that
fascist computer mainframe this will be
too easy smash the side
oh my non-conforming genderless
non-binary - spirit of god what's
happening did they find you no they have
no search history
[Music]
at least what you do online is your
business protect your business
expressvpn it's simple if you use a VPN
great if you don't you should be if you
want to use one use the one that we use
and trust use the link at expressvpn
comm slash Crowder get an extra three
months free on a one-year package
expressvpn comm slash Crowder you should
use a VPN if nothing else after
coronavirus in South Korea and you don't
want your location to be revealed to
your neighbor because here in this
country they could be an toughie you
should use the VPN if you're still not
convinced there is no you know it's not
my job for black rifle coffee company
the Colombian Sun is not just a
fair-weather friend all year round the
Sun keeps the mountain air as mild as
spring for the coffee trees of vanwall
des it is the best climate in the world
supplying only the best coffee beans
from the farm of diligent fun Walden's
to your door
black rifle coffee freshly roasted each
batch to order the best way to enjoy a
black rifle coffee is through the coffee
club chosen coffee is roasted packaged
and shipped free to your door all you
need to do is do two black rifle coffee
dot-com / cloud and order today you know
another Masri co que tener Miharu yen or
the black rifle coffee
cada Lopez de cafes primo de Hory gente
alder or del mundo asada para toward
creado iya parado de veteranos es el
único Capelli know as they have visit
blackrapid.com / Crowder in order today
blackbriar god this is nice yeah yeah I
feel like we don't spend enough time
together like this you know you're busy
I mean I don't know I mean just praying
appropriate minutes obviously I see
you're eating your vegetables lots good
roughage is important yeah you have to
worry about that at your age but when
you get to be mine it adds up yeah yeah
so have you seen Richard Jewell yet no I
haven't I've been meaning to see it oh
yeah it feels pretty good it's good it's
worth it
it's a fascinating story yeah she's
check it out Oh hold on entering this
yeah you have anal fissures watch this
and more and our other channel Crowder
bits
[Music]
and see that song is perfect the Street
Fighter theme song oh yeah because we
all have two together together because
we can't fight we have two together as
one fight Kovan 19 oh that's what this
program is about isn't is showing
everyone that we can only we are only as
strong as our weakest link
serving the weakness like I love our
next guest he's a fantastic
conversationalist one of the best
broadcasters in the business and I mean
that honestly you know you know from
Opie and Anthony show you know I'm
compound media of course you can use a
promo code compound 20 at compound
Mediacom and in case you know you you
know make it your second subscription
service you're the second one but I can
follow them on the Kamiya show Anthony
ku Mia how are you sir
very good I'm here with of course my
co-host dave landau because we're
cohorting together during this whole
party thing it's very strange a lot of
people have been doing the Brady Bunch
boxes right know where they where they
do their show that way but we said screw
it
he's staying here yeah living at my
estate here out on Long Island okay in
the north wing and glad to have him drew
our guy in the I like to call the out of
control room you are a delight
this nightmares are made of
yeah he's living with you in Long Island
and as you referred to the Brady Bunch
box that CNN calls it the golden
standard of broadcasting this is
intrusive when I was on Fox News one
time so they actually because they want
to make it seem more international it
was either either Doug shown or Lonny
Davis you know one of those stuffed
suits and so we were in the same room
but they put us in separate boxes
because they were saying we want people
to feel like you're in different cities
and at the end of the segment I said
whether it was Doug or Lanny I'll go
with Doug's shown he ever taste anymore
today I just said hey Doug put her there
and I put my hand for high five into his
box and I was suspended on air for two
weeks
ah I don't know if I was really
officially suspended but I know for two
weeks all the regular spots were gone
and it was worth it it was worth it so
you're both in in law so - you're both
in Long Island right now I wanted to ask
you can I actually go to a clip first
because obviously New York is a hotbed
for infectious diseases right now oh
yeah and I know you have some strong
opinions on this Anthony and I'm sure
Dave you you do as well let's go to
Governor Cuomo
I always forget if it's Cuomo or de
Blasio being what he be want to be
frankly more aggressive on the
enforcement we're gonna increase the
potential maximum fine from 500 to 1000
dollars but it's not really about - fine
nobody wants the money we want the
compliance okay first i'll answer you by
that that nobody wants the money I mean
someone wants some money of course this
is a guy that throughout his tenure as
governor of the state of New York has
done all these midnight legislation
deals where laws get signed into
unbelievable the highest taxes in the
nation gun regulations that are so
ridiculous that no one ever got to
debate or or try to even put in their
own opinion on get away with it though
every time I see you you you're packin a
new piece I am in compliance with New
York State I will not be one of those
guys that say well I'll just give up or
I'll be illegal they're trying to get
legitimate gun owners to break the law
so they could take their guns away sure
but I I refuse so I go with their crappy
little ten round magazine in my AR it
looks ridiculous it looks like you
pulled your pants down in the locker
room and you got a tiny little friggin
schwanz hanging gun I know the feel of a
30-round banana clip and I got this
little stub coming out of the bottom of
my eye are ya you know
god forbid you have a bayonet lug which
is one of the classifications were an
assault weapon sure because you know how
many robberies have done with a
screaming world
one over the top boys let's type this
train the 7/11 that he's just coming in
with one of those wraps around their
head like it like Marley and Christmas
Carol wrapping his jaw you don't know
what that does like this is not going to
fix your job yeah so I didn't even know
that about bayonets but you you you work
if I'm not mistaken don't you have a
permit to carry in New York yeah yeah I
well I had one for the city but I I'm
reworking on getting that back which
looks impossible it just seems
impossible these days I did it
when Bloomberg was still in office hmm
maybe even Giuliani God it was a long
time ago and now with de Blasio in as
mayor in New York and then there was
some kind of scandal of course because
they were taking payoffs to give people
permits right so that whole thing ended
so I'm good in New York State just not
in the confines of the city where by the
way it's needed more than anywhere else
I was going to sorry in New York things
yeah if nothing else just to to put the
bats out of their misery before
consuming I mean was I know that we're a
little rough around the edges but we're
none for cruelty here right Dave is from
Detroit so he knows some of the minor
aspects of mental patients running
around a city hold on a second Dave
where are you from in Detroit because
everyone says Detroit but where are you
actually from well I'm from where you
were born Grosse Pointe but I hope
Detroit right yeah we do go into Detroit
to buy our guns out of brown paper bags
right yes yes I can't you are the people
who sell them in paper bags they walk
into Grosse Pointe and then they ride
back into Detroit that's very honest you
kind of want to go into their area for
the gun though because cops do stop them
the second thing cross that border yeah
yo my dad is from so he was actually
inside of seven-mile there off of that's
where I was born yeah okay all right
yeah yeah my dad lived this so sometimes
he'll have someone say like oh I'm from
Detroit my Lele don't know no hole
second you're from Saginaw you know your
Mount Pleasant
not the same thing his house I think
went for 700
$45.00 foot in marble he didn't want to
accept how his neighborhood was when we
were driving through it as like wow dad
this is a this is really ghetto sick no
no that was mr. mr. Naples or everything
he used to make handmade canoes my dad
that's a mess
that's a that's a meth house like this
guy's giving me bird calls and trying to
sell me rocks yeah okay so sorry we've
gotten off the beaten path here so New
York how are you what's your perception
there living in New York City how are
they they handling it because all eyes
are on New York right now yeah yeah that
seems that we seem to be the city where
and the state but also New York City is
a huge hotbed as they want to call it
it's terrible it's the you know United
Soviet Socialist Republic of New York
and it's so restrictive I really do
think I don't I'm not crazy enough to
think this is a hoax or or that I I'm
still on the on the fence about whether
it was purposefully put out there by the
Jews is virus I don't know by someone or
something I don't know I don't know as
much as anyone else does it no so what
am I going to just take someone's word
for but the thing is whatever however
this thing spread yeah there are certain
people in government that are using it
way to their advantage I think this is a
test to see how far we could be pushed
and bent over before we say hey enough
and boy we literally spun around shoved
our own heads up our asses because we're
just taking it we really like I'm trying
to think of the physicality because
you're very flowery with your language
but I don't think that spinning around
would assist in putting your head up
your own ass you would have to invert
more so right when you have to go
through the leg I mean like putting
yourself into a kind of a loop okay well
entirely accurate but you know we're a
little rusty today if you want to be I
we don't want to be making news here
right yeah exactly we don't want to be
the world health organization Taiwan's
like yeah you know this is I think a lot
I said this early on that I won't be
shamed into panicking and it's a real
virus obviously and people need to take
precautions but long a long time ago I
said how listen when we look at the
actual mortality rates and we look at
the deaths and one thing - your state by
the way is just registering anyone who
dies who has coronavirus as a corona
death and that's not even the standard
in influenza season meaning if someone
has leukemia and is undergoing treatment
and they have a life expectancy of three
months and they get influenza they don't
just list it as an influenza death but
that's what they're doing with with
kovat 1995 right yeah you know I mean
the Chinese wet market just accelerated
the process a little bit yeah yeah yeah
it's I think if you got into a car
accident at this point
yeah died of massive head trauma and
they somehow figured out you had corona
they would list it as a corona death
right and that's why New York State has
these unbelievably high numbers it's all
going to turn out to be a money grab
once this is all said and done they're
gonna go now we're putting this bill out
there to prepare for the next pandemic
right it's just gonna be everything
under the Sun on the bill it's gonna be
an influx of cash that's unbelievable
right and by the way there will be no
preparation for a pandemic it'll go in
cronies pockets and these crappy
[ __ ]
programs like to make solo C's I browse
hire like what just happen I just we
just sign another stimulus and now every
time we sign a stimulus your eyebrows
guy I don't know I there's no causation
is not correlation and yeah you know
it's it yeah was it was it was the death
due to the oh do these slight air
pockets and a lot no I think it was the
Sumeru on the overall chest cavity but
it you say moneygrab have you seen this
new conspiracy now where they're saying
the reason Donald Trump and they're
really going hard after chloroquine we
early on this they're really going after
and I think it's just because it turns
out he's right and by the way the
science was right so they're going after
it hard now they're trying to say that
someone who is a partial owner in one of
the companies that will be obviously
creating more hydroxychloroquine tablets
visited Trump's golf course like it's a
generic drug bayer people makers of
aspirin will be printing these out like
their you know like their ecstasy
tablets on a little paper paper roll
yeah everyone will it could not be a
less profitable drug the conspiracies
now are just so so outlandish it's
gotten to a point where I don't even
necessarily know how to process the news
so I just go to Jill Biden it sounded
like you drank a bucket of salt water
and a bizarre it's it's anything Trump
does it's you know they've been saying
that if he said it was a horrible drug a
bad drug never used chloroquine it would
be all over the place and the media
would be saying oh my god I can't
believe he's against this miracle drug
right yeah it's a generic now it doesn't
have a that I guess you have a certain
amount of years of exclusivity if you
invent the dry with a patent and after a
while anyone can make it this is like
yeah like you said it's like aspirin
it's like nothing there's no money to be
made and and how many other people from
other businesses have played golf at
Trump's golf course by now it's so
ridiculous how they try to tie
everything in to this guy passing up
leaving his job as one of the richest
guys in America a successful businessman
Donald Trump going into the presidency
where he's not making any money he's
giving it away and trying to make it
sound like this was his scheme yeah yeah
rich right it's no sense what so a
scheme all along was to make to ensure
that China continued their wet markets
in a country that he hates to ensure
that a disease comes over here where he
will receive a very small not quite
sizable but significant kickback from a
company that would be one of many to
print out a generic unprofitable drug
sorry Dave I cut you off I was very rude
I apologize no you're fine I'm just with
you completely the stuffs readily
available anybody can get it and just to
watch people argue was nice to see that
somebody in Michigan in politics did
admit who was on the Democratic side
that her life was saved by that
medication it's readily available
people can get it it's it's in tonic
water it's not like you're buying
anything that's serious it's not like
it's oxy oh wait I thought tonic water
was quinine a little yeah yeah it's
quinine it's not tonic water has quinine
in it I don't think it has a chloroquine
I don't want to get I don't want to have
Snopes fact checking this video
underneath here but all because Dave
Dave decided to get lippy I don't like
to read taste test like the Pepsi
challenge so we covered you know the
story there was everywhere the lady who
drank fish tank cleaner total
speculation by the way I think she offed
her husband that's right yeah I mean I
saw your piece on it it was so good and
I'm just sitting there watching it gone
yeah said that from the start the second
I watched too many episodes of Forensic
Files to not assume this is such a
principle it's gonna be on forensic file
she she looked around saw something that
had chloroquine in it and and decided
what a great way to kill my husband a
good fish tank cleaner opportunist and
you know that's exactly that's what I
believe generally I believe she did he
made some bye-bye tea yeah they'd find
it in ER you know they always thank you
to she's clearly not a murderer yeah
that's those days ever see those cases
on Forensic Files where the the spouse
the significant other is stabbed 82
times right absolutely goes back to the
significant other right
no one wrong time that stabbed you 82
times right yeah I'll learn I think it
might be personal yeah
and then they they stab themselves like
superficially in the shoulder well you
know the weirdest one was a fight of all
but I just exactly what she did she took
a little bit of it and the husband dies
from it she's like oh oh I'm so wet I
don't know if you saw that we called the
NBC reporter because I was gonna hold on
a second the only this should be catnip
to reporters lady kills her husband the
only thing that gets them more hard as
man dies from Trump medical advice and
so they didn't do any due diligence and
she said she's a 12-time to me like you
have a story and that you asked no no
I'll give I don't want the story you
take it you take this information I'm
surprised you didn't look at their
voting records or criminal history they
had no interest whatsoever it is
remarkable to me I think if nothing else
and you've been talking about this is
the media malpractice that is going on
right now the fact that Donald Trump's
approval ratings go up and then I say
let's stop let's stop running the press
briefings he can't talk directly the
American people we have to have Wolf
Blitzer act as an interpreter because
they want to control this yeah yeah it's
it's the way it's been now for years it
was a little shocking I think to America
when we first saw how full of the
mainstream media is and then now they
don't even try to hide it it's it's so
blatantly there for everyone to see that
they're just lying to you right for an
agenda to drive an agenda they they're
either that or they're so stupid they
don't realize that videos are up online
they last forever what you said last
week right is still there yeah you're
completely contradicting it this week
but we have that video of you saying the
opposite last week yeah and I don't know
what their goal is here because like
like you said every time they try this
Trump's numbers just go up it's it's
remarkable speaking of by the way I
don't even know what we're speaking
about but guidelines I think we have
this tweet we can bring up that you
posted about the NYPD or at least it was
there and you you commented and I don't
remember exactly the original source of
a police officer telling a man that he
was going to find him if he didn't put
the distance between him and this lady
and he said what she's she's my wife
said I don't care I'm going to find you
I mean if I'm that man I respond with
okay
find your wife officer I just can't
believe that this is what's going on
right now you gonna find a man for being
next to his wife that's what's happening
in your state there's yeah why not yeah
he's probably like officer I'm gonna sit
with my wife can you find me you know
he's but it's the cop I can't you can't
do anything now I'd love to walk
hand-in-hand with you in the park
sweetie but you know the cops I'm gonna
go home and stay in the house you don't
there is has been just this amazing
authoritarian jump during this whole
thing yeah and the fining thing is
ridiculous if you're supposed to be
helping people I could see going around
and going hey you know we're trying to
keep people apart right like a high
school dance and a wife obviously you're
gonna be together but then they're
outside maybe they're bumping into
people they shouldn't be I don't know
but but maybe just say hey people you're
not supposed to do this
not the fine like like yeah he says the
money doesn't matter like well mo said
it matters believe me did you get in
that New York City for double parking
and speeding and and red light cameras
all those things right all about money
look nothing's about saying look at the
size of the ticket - you're taking away
people's ability to make a living and
then you're charging them for it and
putting them on house arrest might be
all DUI
who would've thought it's the biggest
act of rebellion we could think up in
the year 2020 would be wanting to go to
work and have sex with your wife that's
punk rock right there without a cause
what's your cause your wife bad man I
know we are all just zany characters I
really pissed off I've talked about this
tomorrow I pissed off people at the
urgent clinic because I thought I broke
my foot it just turns out I tore some
crap in there and I went in and they
were really upset about you know
coronavirus they wouldnt let my wife
come in on okay so I put on a mask and
sanitizer I actually brought my own mask
and let me bring it use this mask as a
mine's better and they said well use
ours I said what
No so that was inserted off on the wrong
foot and I said so have you had a lot of
coronavirus patients and not the doctor
the doctor was very nice but the nurse
practitioner who was the guy said he
said yeah too many and I said well what
do you got you have a like you have a
lot of them like a lot of them are very
soon you deaths said no not none yet
here I said if you had any any like have
you got any young people which is out of
the blue or you know they're on like are
you running out of ventilators or people
who you would never you know you'd never
see it come and he said no not not so
much with young people and so I said oh
okay so so just the dry cough mostly you
don't think it's that serious then maybe
you shouldn't sanitize your hands like
what what how did it escalate this
quickly and then they charged me $100
for a motrin shot in my ass that's what
they gave me they were like it's motrin
I was like and then they gave me a bill
for a hundred bucks and like I that's
expensive ibuprofen couldn't you have
told me beforehand sorry I'm burdening
with you with this it's been a rough day
Anthony from pulp fiction like was he
just covered from head to toe with
goggles on no he what yeah like a like a
minion no he no just your average
self-important and scrubs me I don't
like I don't like the idea that male
nurses are dressed absolutely like
doctors no surgeons like specialty - yes
surgeon yes yes I honestly think they
should have to wear the white dress with
the with like it's a 1940s movie like
that nurse right exactly and by the way
let's be clear they're all heroes every
single one of them 100% comparable to
New York firefighters after 9/11 were
just talking about the uniforms those
guys who went down to the towers down to
Ground Zero who are still coughing up
suit right you know about 20 years later
yeah child's play compared to walking in
on a patient who hasn't taken his
elderberry syrup they don't know to us
where this is already demise
going very well hey did you guys watch
obviously because you've spent a lot of
time with me you guys are friends the
new louis c.k special and have you seen
sort of the controversy turning it yes
its first of all I just really sorry I
wif you hold that thought
let's we're gonna go this is where if it
weren't a Mudd Club quarantine right
promo code quarantine you get $30 off we
would go to a break and close and then
it would go to web extended but you get
all this for free so just real quick
[Music]
know Arizona this cafe Thomas Iago
casinos como Bulger meet a noise black
rifle coffee
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
go to black rifle coffee dot-com slash
brother use promo code growler for 20%
off your first purchase mmm
so end if the tail of van well des I'm
glad half-asian Bill's not here today
we're fine
black rifle coffee calm slash Crowder
use a promo code
Crowder you get 20% off your first order
listen if you drink coffee drink better
coffee and support a veteran owned
company but most importantly it's fresh
roasted so it's just better I'm a coffee
snob you don't even want to know how
snobby I am because I paced myself don't
worry I have another back we have so
many bags here because that's all we
drink black raffle coffee comes flush
crowd are entering from a co Crowder 20%
off if you don't drink coffee then just
you should skip twice the speed hey guys
lower 22 here you may know a recent
story from the folks at plummet exposing
Governor Andrew Cuomo's very clearly
defined nipple piercings pretty
open-and-shut case right not so fast
the real meat of this story began with
neocon shill and confirmed twig aren't
beta male steven crowder had this to
stay right there that might not be
nipple rings holdout nipple hair yeah
and has those little like goose bumps
come on shouter it's so obvious that
only a solid material could make that
kind of an impression through cloth so
why would he pretend otherwise unless he
has something to hide unless Browder not
only has twig arms but he also has a
prince albert hey this this for my wife
me this this my wife
thanks for watching guys huge
announcement really quick i've just been
signed with an MCN recently so prepare
yourselves for truth with more out foot
bucket it's the perfect size when you've
torn soft tissue and caused ligament
damage in your feet this one's generic
so they're not sponsoring the show but i
would love for them to do so because
it's the perfect foot bucket for ice
it's not too big not too small there's
no condensation so we would love to be
sponsored by foot buckets and offer
discounts for people who I'm pretty
flexible that's just the illest analyst
right here but look look look at that
that is a perfect ice foot bath if I've
ever seen one it's not it's not gangrene
foot buckets foot buckets please
consider sponsoring the program foot
buckets
[Music]
watch this and more at our other channel
the Crowder bits
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I came here prepared for the journey
against because this is my right foot is
my scooting foot when I scoot back the
chair it's usually my right foot I've
never scooted with a looking foot it's
very sad I've never done that with the
left foots kind of like an inchworm yeah
yeah but it's my foot yeah but my foot
will be fine there's no need to amputate
and for people who are confused Anthony
come here we went so the timer stopped
working and we didn't take these on the
East Coast and he didn't want to go
super late we taped like 40 something
minutes so it is available for just
uploading that full interview separately
as opposed to this show and by the way
thank you again so much promo code is
quarantine you get $30 off it is mug
club quarantine month tomorrow morning
we will see you will be talking a little
bit about rhett and Link we did the mass
Monday but which we thought was the
friendliest thing we've ever done
obtained their producer call me be that
as it may I have no problem with someone
calling me if he's I just am curious as
to why you think I'm a pieces so we talk
about that more a little bit tomorrow
and probably do the math I think another
Mass Monday is warranted there that
calling someone homes it is brand
friendly which seems to be the focus and
or link yeah and those are both names TV
names so a couple others is usually
where I try and close and provide some
sort of inspiration or advice but I am
the tired and I actually just wanted to
read something that was inspirational to
me from one of you out there so this was
a year ago actually on the life advice
installment we got a letter from a
gentleman who was blind and for people
who don't remember I don't know if this
went up on YouTube or if it was for only
for mug Club members I mean jog your
memory I've been blind since 13 and I'm
24 now I'm sorry to hear that yeah Oh
ever since I've lost my sight I I've
noticed that I've been forced into
limitations that keep me from living a
life that I wanted one thing that we'll
say is missing from here and that's a
dream
yeah that's goals and listen.i goals
change dreams change its
people need to know that it's okay to
change your goals and your dreams yeah
and that was uh you know that was that
was a fun day and you know what yeah
pretty sure we made fun of him quite a
bit
yeah we gave some really disability as
one does he can take it uh but in a
friendly way and hopefully you know when
you do this now we'll say this as well I
want to hear you guys comment below here
you guys read you guys comment below I'm
obsessed with the blind and hearing
smell smell will I'll smell do a scratch
and sniff with the comments could you
imagine throws questions comments on
YouTube it's like whoa it smells like
smells like a pit of sulfur and for some
reason Jimi Hendrix let's not gonna do
that
um so this is uncomfortable as possible
because I read something earnest you
know we do these things we do this life
advice or whatever his mess Monday and
you know it's it's separate rooms for
the pomp and circumstance and the jokes
that we do and sometimes I'm talking to
a brick wall right like I'm advised not
to read the comments always because I
get lost in it and usually the people
who hate you the most or the people who
comment first so everyone else kind of
gets to sort of a chip in and enjoy some
of the feedback I don't always get a pat
in the back and I would like to know
what you guys would like to see more of
here with Mudd Club quarantine month now
that we're halfway through because weeks
of it we've done some experimental
streams video gaming you know Mass
Monday life advice we told you that not
everything's gonna they can't all be
gems but we are trying different things
to see what it is it works and what it
is that connects us with you the most
effectively so let us know let us know
what you like to see more below and I'll
have a carrot read them but same thing
with reading these life advice emails
sometimes they come to the website at
life advice at laterthe CARICOM and the
gentleman wrote me another letter and i
want to read it says hello mr. Crowder
the entire a lot of credit family I
don't know if you remember me but I was
a young man who emailed into the life
advice almost exactly a year ago where I
talked about my blindness and the
subsequent struggles with my mental
health that it caused I do remember you
we don't get that many blind emails yeah
not not a big shun rrah of email is no
it's it's nice yeah but I appreciate it
vapor are the keyboards Braille
they must be they've got to be right
well I guess not at that point it's all
tactile like that probably Braille is
almost absolutely because of the
keyboard
well if you're typing none of anyway I
should read this letter too complicated
okay again I cannot thank you enough for
both the advice in the kind gesture of
the Mudd Club subscription you gave me
well I appreciate that it meant that
much to you I'm not exaggerating when I
say legitimately believe those simple
acts saved me from myself the main
reason I'm emailing you is because I
wanted to share where I am now from
where I was a year ago I'm back in
school like I planned and I'm about to
finish my junior year so I only have one
more year left for my bachelor's degree
however I'm actually considering going
to law school because I found myself
more and more interested in pursuing
that career from watching the legal
struggles you all have had as well as
being captivated when mr. Richmond
that's half-asian mr. Richmond to you
buddy listen that hall oh but I'm blind
stick may work with the professors but
not here
when mr. Richmond has discussed his
profession and the law more generally
not only do I find this subject
incredibly interesting I want to be able
to help fight the good fight like mr.
Richmond yes I completely understand and
laugh at the daredevil comparison so
don't feel bad about laughing at it to
context we made fun of him and we
daredevil it was a legitimate question
if his other heightened senses were
heightened yeah so he didn't answer that
wasn't a joke I'm on a thirty mission I
want to show what is it don't feel bad
my passion project the music is taking a
little bit of a backseat as I focus on
school but I still dedicate time to it I
want to show everyone that you can be
something other than a far-left
progressive ideologue and make it in the
entertainment industry like you have mr.
Crowder you mustn't be afraid to aim
your sights a little higher love with
regards to my mental health I'm in a
much better place than I was before I'm
certainly not saying I'm perfect and I
still have moments of weakness but I do
feel like there is a light at the end of
the tunnel that I am moving toward for
the first time since I can remember
maybe the road ahead will still be hard
but I no longer feel like I'm stumbling
in the dark well as much as a blind
person doesn't stumble in the dark when
they have a light at the end of the
tunnel I appreciate cuz you can make
those jokes take advantage thank you
again for all the kindness you have
shown me and I hope I can make you all
proud also I renewed my Mudd Club
subscription and was able to pay for it
myself which was something that even
though it may seem small made me
incredibly happy I'm glad to support all
of you and being part of this movement
is the first time I felt like I belong
anywhere my blindness has always made me
feel like an outsider but now I've found
a new home
thank you his name PS I'm sorry I sent
my letter to this email but I wasn't
sure where else to send it also my email
was giving me trouble and I don't know
well I don't really care about your
technical issues okay you know much you
had earned some points then use wasting
my time you know people sometimes in
this office hear me talk about like you
know listen sometimes when you're the
boss you don't get a lot of Pat's on the
back thank you that's it
that does it that's that's when I see
that it makes it's been a very tiring
exhausting a couple of weeks and not
really I want to be clear not just not
because I've done the Mudd Club
quarantine in two shows a day and we
have it you know we're doing it with a
skeleton crew oh no I just touched my
eyes ah now I'm gonna be like the email
guys you there and some things some
technical issues behind the scenes
hiccups uh my foot which is really just
my fault that I'm a [ __ ] and something
else happens too though this is this is
this is why this means a lot to me and
this is not really inspirational so much
as it is a thank you and I understand
that many of you are in tough times and
cannot afford to join my club so
understand that I'm not trying to sell
you something that you don't want or
can't afford I'm just asking if it's
something that you do want and you want
the show to continue that you know you
make that so because we can't do it
without you this is there's a difference
a lot of people get to separate their
their job their career in their home
life particularly this month this is it
this is a hundred percent of what I am
of Who I am every moment pretty much is
spent doing this show now two shows a
day several days a week for you guys and
that can be that can be pretty tiring
anyone who's ever spoken from a large
group of people sometimes you forget
that you know a millions of people are
watching here there's still that
pressure everyone in here feels that
when the cameras go on oh I forgot that
point yeah because you know someone's
gonna give you crap for it so it is
tiring and we do this thing before the
show called the is it the Alpen do we
call it the alphabet game of a game we
do yeah we do some warm-up games to try
and you know enhance verbal fluidity and
short-term recall and sometimes we do an
alphabet game where we go and every
person has to name a word that starts
with the letters so a you know might be
for doing animals it might be like a Alf
albatross bee
I don't even know that's how this is the
point the air bear humbleby see the
point is no and and I for me I've always
liked the thing that I you sure have
realized who you are when you're really
tired or at least what your natural
capabilities are like I've seen audio
way to be very tired and you can sing
you can sing with the best quarterback
here it'd be very tired and then come
out with a amazing to scale replica of
r2d2 so accurate that when I was like
hey what's this thing there he was
offended
let me not appreciating the detail but
I'm sure if I were to ask you to do
something like that isn't your
wheelhouse when you're tired it's hard
and same thing 3 I was been doing the
warm-up game like I don't know how to do
this but then when I sit in the chair
and do this show I'm able to do it I
really am
and it's always panic before every show
my wife knows this before every live
show proof every performance and I'm
sure the comment section because you
suck and be that as it may
these are according to rhett and Link um
they always say well you know what when
you sit in the chair when you go on
stage you're going to go into autopilot
and I don't believe that in the back of
my mind I don't trust it so I always
over prepare I over prepare so that I
can sort of be off-the-cuff and a little
more conversational here but I will say
that they're kind of right so I will
come in I won't be able to think of an
animal that starts with B has happened
today but then we did that show which
you know what pretty proud of that show
considering then one on this week I
think was a pretty fun show and Anthea
Kamiya makes everyone better and Stu
makes everyone better but the point I'm
getting at is is is a reason it means so
much to me I think everyone hears I can
do that even when I'm exhausted
compared to accounting because this is
what I was born to do it really is and
so when I see people out there and I
sort of see it was mentioned this
because I think it sort of came a little
bit from rhettandlink where they were
doing that interview we did that last
Monday and they're talking about how and
we try to stay relevant on YouTube and
people want you to do things that you
don't want to do for me and I'm not
saying this is the case with them but
you hear it from a lot of artists anyone
who is exasperated with their fans
doesn't deserve the privilege of
performing for them and it is a
privilege and
I am incredibly grateful and I know that
I only deserve I don't even deserve this
privilege but I can only earn this
privilege by doing what it is that I was
designed to do born to do because if I'm
tired and I can't remember anything else
when I sit here something happens and it
doesn't really occur to me it's not
really about me at this point it's not
about people in the room we really are
all of us trying to design this content
same thing this month created for the
people out there like this guy I don't
want to say his name so I know that
sounds that sounds not very for like
this guy there's a dish blind I'm trying
to not say his name so for me when I say
like you don't get a lot of Pat's on the
back as a boss it's been an exhausting
grueling couple of weeks and I know it
will be this month that's all it takes
and you know what I think that's the
case for everyone out there particularly
for men just knowing that hey this is
what I can do this is what I can offer
not like this month not a doctor not a
first responder this is what I can do
and that it not only means something to
somebody because well that's enough
someone laughing for me is enough
because that means something to somebody
but that it actually has affected real
change for someone to improve their life
I don't give a rat's ass what people in
Silicon Valley say what they do if they
want to shut us down right now where do
you monetize they want to shut the
channel down that makes it worth it and
I really really appreciate it and would
love to hear from you what it is that
you want to see more because we don't
the moan it we are here to serve you
this month and beyond thank you so much
don't forget tomorrow morning good
morning mug Club 9:00 a.m. Eastern I got
to get up at 3:30 worth it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
Christopher Robin
what exactly is doing nothing well I
tell it means gabbing along listening
for all the things you can't hear and
not bothering
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
listening to all the things you can tell
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you